[Music]
welcome back to zero hour i'm bill
bryans with many professionals leaving
the medical field americans are looking
for a new type of treatment from nfl
quarterbacks to nut job influencers this
turn against sound advice from your
doctor is beginning to carry the stench
of horse
podcasters are now the world's leading
experts in therapeutics tonics elixirs
serums snake oils parasiticides and yes
even vaccines
our country is now in a different type
of remedy timeline and tonight i'm
joined by two podcasters to discuss this
berserk blueprint joe rogan and tony
michaels thank you both for joining me
joe what gives you the confidence to
give anyone medical advice related to
the coronavirus well it's not rocket
surgery i threw the kitchen sink at it
and now i'm cured cured says the guy
took [ __ ] horse dewarmer jesus christ
it wasn't horse based it was prescribed
by a doctor prescribed by a doctor not
ivermectin is a dewormer you [ __ ]
bonehead you sound just like the woke
mob at cnn enough gentlemen let's try to
reign it in joe how do you go about
getting prescribed divermectin well a
doctor of course and let me be clear
before i get canceled it was an online
doctor where does this doctor work the
florida ivermectin institute of q and on
technology what are the batshit crazy
stuff that this doctor inject you with
monoclonal antibodies z-pack antibiotics
and a vitamin drip
must be nice to have the hater can
afford that kind of [ __ ] you and
karen rogers both so joe did aaron
rodgers of the green bay packers just
call you up for a prescription of
ivermectin yeah he consulted me about my
protocol on a facebook dm protocol jesus
[ __ ] christ dr dunnin krueger here
thinks he's some kind of coveted expert
what next you gonna take a bath in borax
oh get off your [ __ ] high horse i
don't believe everything on the internet
[ __ ] you and the horse you rode in on oh
this horse gladly
uh all right well thank you both for
joining me this evening
wow not sure if joe was going for dr
jackal or mr jackass but i'm bill
bryan's and this is the news you already
knew